I have to say to my fans this is this is
a beautiful moment don't trip on wins or
losses and the Grammy goes too
Ozzy Osbourne patient number nine it's
like an honor to be in the category with
Ozzy yeah Machine Gun Kelly left the
Grammys empty-handed but to his fiance
Megan Fox The Rocker still won big when
someone's like your life partner the
help comes and the day after the award
ceremony Meg posted a sweet tribute to
her man writing congratulations on being
the very small percentage of artists who
have received a Grammy nomination and
even though he lost the trophy Meg
thinks he won in a different way you
have handled this process with a Grace
and maturity that I haven't seen from
you before and I'm so proud of you and
as MGK told E.T last year right after he
found out he was Grammy nominated just
being in the category was a prize in and
of itself I think like a form of closure
on is sticking with the journey and like
you know wondering like is there really
light at the end of the tunnel I mean
they gave me a little gift this is the
envelope where they read my name on it
I'm a hoarder so this is going to stay
in my house MGK's first ever nod was
thanks to last year's album mainstream
sellout
so I think that the success came because
I made people uncomfortable and made
them think about what art was happening
in front of them so I think I just gave
them a painting that maybe they weren't
used to and their eyes opened up a
little bit like oh I gotta check this
out ET caught up with the 30 year old on
the red carpet at the Grammys shortly
after he learned he lost his mood Good
Vibes only it was more cathartic and
more
um
I learned a bigger lesson in the
45-minute car ride that I had on the way
here than I think I've learned in 30
years and like that was
it's the beginning of my uh
my journey of self-worth on Saturday the
day before the Grammys Megan supported
this hand brace at a pre-party telling
fans on Instagram she suffered a broken
wrist and concussion no explanation for
now she'd rather praise Kelly's humility
and gratitude I'm very happy and I'm
very grateful the actress Gus quote
watching you grow into yourself and
become a better man is an immeasurably
more satisfying experience than watching
you accept an award as for trophies she
promises those will come in time the win
is being here the wind is the journey
whatever daddy said but for now the PDA
obsessed couples got plenty of keepsakes
from their love story remember those
blood vial necklaces but Megan says the
biggest night in music will last a
lifetime I'm just kind of at the whim of
the waves of the universe quote I hope
one day you'll see yourself the way I
see you I'll keep this memory of you
forever I am so grateful grateful Beyond
you don't even know thank you guys I
love you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign